nothing like the bay all right going
back through history of these events
DeSean Jackson Marshawn Lynch Shaq
Thompson Clay Matthews Jared Goff
Michael Kendricks DeMarco Murray Colin
Kaepernick Kiko Alonso and Dom akin to
Giambi cannon Doug Martin Brandon cooks
just to name a few of the guys that have
been the exact same spot you guys are at
right here getting ready to step out
here and prove to have that opportunity
to come to the opening we hear it we say
it we believe it
but can we see the effect
the games online you can see in a
person's eyes it's noticeable the effect
they make the players around them better
be effective welcome to the in Factory
I'm excited to see you Dylan yep yep yep
yep
you know his brother and the family
history grown up with the game was a lot
of pressure and we were just like okay
this is something I really wanna do but
none of my family fortune ever to play
that's what made me fall in love with it
it wasn't even just being around on all
the times is that I gotta choose to be
around it as well then we get our first
look at a - a tackle by Lowe also out of
Hawaii I was kind of nervous how could
somebody from Hawaii compete with the
outer States so it's Hawaii versus the
mainland we're small but there's a lot
of good things happening over there
we got a couple guys coming back from
the LA one I mean it was two full months
ago SARS right up Jackson LA every
quarterback kinda grows up with a dream
that they want to go lead 11 it's been
the last opportunity when pressures on
us when big players step up I feel like
I can deliver and then you always got
our North Cal sleepers - there's always
a good guy in Northern California that's
under recruited for whatever reason so
should be good
lot of you guys been waiting for this
day to show up it's here this is your
last go-around this is your last
opportunity so understand that the hair
popping up on your arms it better be
because we're gonna challenge you today
telling McCaffrey why are you stand up
you're a really good football player
great pedigree right knowing you're your
family forever I gotta figure out where
you can pass down to a stand up you're a
phenomenal athlete you're a baller but
you have no discipline playing this
position yo you talked about the in
factor or the in factor is now quiet
your mind and going out there and
absolutely bawling you hear me
dime that's a dime right there come on
now Jack come on now can go to one
regional if you don't get invited go
show up another one like Jack Sears did
in Oakland and he showed up a completely
different guy I want to grow up and look
like Jack Sears rip it jack next one rep
Jack that's a hell of a job pal one of
the best performances I've ever seen in
the history of regionals in LA I kind of
strayed away from who I was I was having
fun but I wasn't showing and so when I
got out to Oakland I said no one's got
more fun than me out here that's it
that's a jock nice Jack good I like how
quick you threw it - don't act that's
good you got it out on time you didn't
have to take the extra step that's good
I accomplished why once I got better I
competed with the best I don't think
anyone had more fun that I did seriously
mcafee are gonna make it a while and
then there's kind of sleeper everybody's
excited about Vayner the virtual on I'm
six foot and a half 190 pounds you know
I'm just trying to come out here and
compete put my best foot forward of your
day there go this guy has a unique trait
he's precise he's a surgeon playing the
position now he's 6 feet 1/2 inch you
have to be better than everybody else at
everything you do to make up for that
being my favorite thing about Jake is he
understands that and he's set out to do
that you play any other sport it's like
golf baseball what do you say what'd he
shoot golf us 74 34
I didn't tell john-boy no I didn't got
it nice nice read
he'd kick your ass in golf he's it too
I don't look too easy really a 274 he
says right now he's he's so in passers
like golf they love this strategy they
love the tactical part it calms me and
it keeps me level-headed all the time
and that's one thing I I take from in I
really value from the game of golf but
all if you don't hit perfect shot after
perfect shot there is a game of misses
so it's how well you manage your shots
order back many times is the same way
I've seen you do the work here I mean
but it's gonna be somebody like you is
gonna always have to how hard work like
we talked about and out lonely work now
but I could do your thing Thank You
Trent I'm with you on Dylan Jack his MVP
right now and to her the thing with two
uh was was he gonna be able to be
disciplined enough to learn the pocket
stuff
the drops be on time understand how to
read a playbook and actually work
through the different reason he's gonna
have to do and Trent challenged him
without an Oakland Seco doing a damn
drill right watch this film I said I get
your physical freak out a big army you
don't play this position
anyway that's transferable to the next
level okay go Oh bad ball that ball turn
my bad down my fault not to be rude not
disrespectful but the best kids here
from coast you know from your boom
sometimes you gotta see what they're
made out of nice crab
I'll babble babble at the end of the day
it doesn't really matter how I felt I
guess I should say you know it's really
up to the coaches ready set go
I like to eye to eye only problem is
that you finished over here Emma we're
gonna get that will TV show that's it
what I love the fact I think you're
better under center bubble Thank You
coach I really do okay thank you
I felt I did all right throughout the
process but I just got to keep working I
can never be satisfied great group of
quarterbacks today
some guys validated what we saw on tape
they're punching a ticket to the Elite
11 finals in Los Angeles our MVP from
today Jack Sears come on up jack
crevalle christian in colorado Dillon
McCaffrey congratulations buddy st.
Louis High School in Hawaii
do a tackle by llola to Ramana Vista
High School jkhanner yeah Jay let's
finish it up let's break it out nice and
loud
I'm short and I might not be the fastest
you know what I am and I am I could I
could sling the rock so you know I'm not
gonna let two inches to find me as a
human being I got what I got let's go
the people thing about the elite eleven
is that there's this collection of
athletes that aren't just throwers
aren't just runners but now this
position has fully developed I really
think in 18 years
illegal Emmons history it is the best
group of pastors who meet athletes were
absolutely gonna shred the competition
as they move forward in that career I
got shot I did to the finals in the
middle of it don't be LA and then though
w24 quarterbacks in there and hopefully
I get a body like they'll cut it down to
12 people 12 quarterbacks to go to work
so I make its that